let's talk about Obama's official
Network MSNBC they just loved him over
there and actually a former employee of
MSNBC a producer on Donahue do you
remember Phil Donahue had a show on
MSNBC his show actually got canceled
literally on the eve of the Iraq war
because he was against the Iraq war so
that shows you how times change but his
producer Jeff Cohen wrote a blistering
open letter about what MSNBC has become
and I thought it was pretty interesting
let's take read when it comes to issues
of u.s. militarism and spying the
alleged progressive MSNBC seems closer
to the official network of the Obama
White House than anything resembling an
independent channel with a few
exceptions especially Chris Hayes MSNBC
has usually reacted to expanded
militarism and surveillance by
downplaying the abuses or defending them
had McCain or Romney defeated Obama and
implemented the exact same policies
treating whistleblowers like Manning and
Snowden as foreign espionage agents one
would expect MSNBC hosts to be loudly
denouncing the Republican abuses of
authority but with Obama in power a
number of MSNBC Talking Heads have
reacted to the Snowden disclosures like
Fox News host did when they were in
hysterical damage control mode for Bush
complete with ridiculously fact-free
claims and national chauvinism that
we've long come to expect from the fair
and balance Channel I mean that is a
pretty scathing attack from a former
employee not just an employee a producer
of a prime-time show on the network and
I pretty much agree with everything that
he said there MSNBC has become as bad to
the left as Fox News is to the right
we've talked about this a bunch on this
show are they just the official network
of the administration pretty much I
don't think that's it's like nobody
doesn't know that unless you're living
under a rock and then Fox is the same
way to the right I think any news
channel in America is biased they're all
skewed one way or another that I think
there's a lot more left
you know leaning news organizations so
that's why I always like to watch BBC I
like to watch foreigner even Al Jazeera
has some some some stories that you can
read that aren't so biased to party
besides you know and going down lines
and just Oh giving blind passes to
whatever you know whoever they agree
with oh yeah sure of course but then if
Bush did it it would be like the end of
the world
well so I don't put much he's surprised
I mean he went to work at this you know
he produced at this network did he not
know what MSNBC was before you and well
they weren't that bad when he was doing
it that's true you know twelve years ago
you're exactly right do you think this
is worse because when it's on the side
of power then it's actually worse you
know do you mean like Fox News is going
against the power now not that I'm
defending Fox News but and everybody
wants to take down you know whoever has
the most power but that's the thing I'm
wondering the same thing who didn't know
this was yeah like I mean this is
brought to you from the Institute of no
[ __ ] we all know this this is not
breaking new I mean yes MSNBC is more
liberal yes Fox is more conservative
what what am I missing something that's
what I read this article five times and
I was like see The Crying Game it was
like there's a secret there's a secret
I'm like okay the credits are rolling I
must have missed the second do they have
something to do with the chick with the
penis because I knew that from the
beginning what am I missing in this
article yeah you think it's even more
obvious like wait a minute okay so do
you think that articles like this
because this stuff is now being written
all the time like it used to be
everything was against Fox one way but
this kind of stuff is popping up now is
this just because we get such tailored
news because we're getting news from
Twitter so you pick the people you like
you follow news that just reinforces
everything you believe that you like I
mean you're not gonna watch Game of
Thrones if you don't like that kind of
storyline I mean you know what I mean
you're gonna watch Breaking Bad or
whatever so people choose what they sure
it's kind of the same beliefs it's the
same you know it's like going to church
you go to the Church of the belief that
you follow because you're like yeah
that's what I believe in so that's what
I'm gonna go with I mean you know it
like I said but it's so bias and skewed
and I think it didn't help that this
administration's spokesman has been very
aloof and a lot of things doesn't like
to answer a lot of things and MSNBC has
been very supportive of that and not
really questioning them and not really
making it you know when he's turning
down people that have
in the press corps for 20 years and not
answering questions and being
transparent like the government said
they would be it's you know it gets very
frustrating so when other liberal
networks are actually calling them the
official network of the Obama White
House then then then you have to go boom
something might be wrong here is that
the bigger problem that we I think
people that are on the left or that are
progressive we expect the left to be a
little better yeah we expect them feel
the police and they just simply can yeah
I think control it's like a locomotive
that's kind of gotten if they forgot
like where are the brakes and gone
everybody wants to think that the side
that they that they align with is the
one that that is the most balanced that
is not just telling people what they
want to hear and I think that we all
have to kind of wake up to that because
my own my presets on my radio in my car
are super super conservative radio and
public radio and I just back and forth
back and forth depending on when certain
people are on agency so I do something
similar to on Twitter I actually follow
a lot of people that I don't like just
so I can chime in and get some sense
whatever just to get a thank you I mean
I like that you know I lean more
conservative I'm more liberal or
libertarian than anything you know so
I'm just like kind of government stay
out of my way I'm not crazy religious or
anything I'm just a fiscally
conservative and money and then policy
and things like that but it's like I'm
liberal and all my other things gay
marriage great you know abortion you
know it's not my cup of tea but I'm not
gonna stop anybody from doing their own
thing you know what I mean so I kind of
fit into the middle of these two worlds
which is bizarre so I kind of have to
look at both sides and I think that
makes people well-rounded yeah well
actually this is a total sidebar to this
but today is Elisabeth Hasselbeck last
day on the view and she's now moving so
she's moving to Fox and Friends no
surprise to anyone but I think you're
hitting on something that's really
interesting is that she was really I
guess too conservative somehow for ABC
which is bizarre cuz I think she
actually for 10 years I think that was
like a good run and she also did an
incredible job I mean she was dealing
with Joy Behar and Rosie O'Donnell and
like so aligned and there's some of the
best seasoned comics that we have on on
the left and female blah blah blah but
is there something dangerous about
someone like her a pretty rat I think a
pretty
how can I say this without everyone is
hacking me a pretty sane conservative or
socially liberal but fiscally
conservative uh if someone like that
can't exist on the networks that's an
even bigger problem don't you think yeah
and when you said rat I was hoping you
were to say radical but you're all
different yes but I agree it's like ten
years who gets to do that I mean I think
that was a success as far as agencies
concerned so I'm not even unless they're
spinning it that way cuz it's sour
grapes closing ABC wouldn't have kept
her on for ten years if they if she did
not pull ratings yeah I mean let's face
it they have and then having her it was
almost like oh well throw the little
right-wing conservative girl in the
corner and see how she fares against all
these Rottweilers and pit bulls and she
did for ten years you know and I think
that you've networks they're all about
money and they're all about ratings and
they're all about advertising and if she
wasn't pulling in any of those as part
of that group she would have gone a long
time ago and I'm I'm from Kansas I'm
from the Midwest and you know they're
always looking for someone to represent
the great unwashed as Lee used to be
called the flyover state of America
right because apparently we're all the
same
Jew from Kansas by the way so we're not
all the same um but I think that she was
she was the representative of all of the
flyover States and everyone else just
got to just do their thing
you